look up
Everest look down
until recently more human beings have
flown to the Moon than have dived to the
deepest spot on earth now thanks to a
singular feat of engineering that is no
longer true it's called the limiting
factor and it looks like something out
of a Pixar movie but this sub is no
cartoon earlier this summer CBS Sunday
Morning correspondent Lee Cowan joined
an expedition to the Mariana Trench in
the Western Pacific to see a vehicle
that some are calling the space shuttle
of the deep blue sea
when you see our Big Blue Marble from
space
striking really we are so much more surf
than Turf and it even today so many of
our oceans remain largely a mystery the
stuff of Tall Tales of sea monsters and
sunken treasure and daring Adventures to
the bar
I'll never forget the Disney version of
20 000 Leagues Under the Sea are you
kidding that probably put the kernel of
the idea of like saying yeah I want a
submarine one day why not for most
people that childhood fantasy would be
crushed by the weight of adulthood but
not for Texas Adventurer and Explorer
Victor viscode in 2016 he set about an
around the world first to dive to the
deepest parts of all five of our oceans
how could this be that it's the year
2016 and we've never been to the bottom
of four of our world's oceans nobody no
one part of the problem is there simply
wasn't a manned vehicle capable of
multiple Dives to deaths that deep not
even the U.S military has won that close
so viscolo built his own forged in fire
he called it limiting factor
it's okay yeah it's hard but I thought
that would be an amazing technological
Challenge and a great adventure anything
deeper than 20 000 feet is known as The
hadel Zone a reference to Hades the
Greek god of the underworld it only
makes up a tiny fraction of our oceans
about two percent
and that can make funding a trip to the
bottom a pretty hard sell for the bottom
line so when you go to the accountants
they say I need all this money to get
that extra two percent they say no you
don't
[Laughter]
Australian subpilot and
it's financing a submarine by themselves
but the Scoville who had made a fortune
in private equity and I've only had the
interest but Pockets deep enough for the
Deep once you're comfortable I think
there's a strong urge to try and do
something helpful for the rest of
humanity in just the area that I've
chosen is ocean exploration he partnered
with Triton submarine a small
manufacturer in Vero Beach Florida who
took on the challenge to make a sub that
could dive to almost unlimited deaths
over and over and over again like a
spaceship to the bottom of the world
the first task was to design a hull that
could withstand the weight of about 20
fully loaded 747s stacked on top of it
that's how much water weight would try
to squeeze its occupants into Oblivion
only a perfect sphere would distribute
the pressure equally they built one out
of titanium got to be fit to be a
Submariner sometimes to go big means to
go small oh man look at this the capsule
is just big enough to fit a pilot and
one passenger and all the controls I
feel like I'm sitting in like the first
Apollo capsule you kind of are the
schedule for tomorrow primary Mission
planner New Zealander Rob McAllen
founder of iOS Expeditions said no one
had ever built a sub capable of more
than one dive that deep were there a lot
of naysayers like you're not going to be
able to build this for more than one
trip they were they would have been they
Sayers but we we purposefully kept the
project confidential until we us through
sea trials
like deep sea creatures themselves the
submersible had to work with the ocean's
pressure not fight it even though the
titanium capsule is over three inches
thick its two hemispheres are almost
fluid so they're not bolted together
they're not they're not welded together
they're held together by by a band
which allows the submersible to flex the
same is true for the three viewports
which you might think would be the
weakest points but as Tim explains
they're designed to essentially get more
waterproof the deeper you go the windows
the viewports are just acrylic
so it's just plastic seriously very very
thick plastic yeah and the fact that
it's shaped in the cone so that as the
pressure gets applied to the viewport it
actually seals more and more and more
think of it as a champagne cork in
Reverse you see anything scrubbers are
going on the limiting factor is
certified for depths more than 20
percent deeper than anything planet
earth has to offer a margin of safety
that viscovo demanded good to go and yet
until she was in the water all bats were
off when we first started testing the
submersible there are all sorts of
little Creeks pings pops and of course
any sound like that when you're in a
submersible that you're testing as a
test pilot it can be concerning
most of the places he's taken her down
to no human eyes had ever seen his first
stop was the deepest part of the
Atlantic the Puerto Rico trench what was
that moment like for you it was just
wonderful to be in one of the most
remote places on the planet with a
vehicle of my own
construction and literally having a
stick in my hand being able to go
wherever I wanted on the bottom of the
ocean like a kid I felt like I was 10
years old it was great in the months
afterward the limiting factor did indeed
push the bottom of all five oceans
including several trips to the deepest
of all Challenger Deep and Abyss deeper
than Mount Everest is tall is this the
time I tell you I've been a lifelong
customer
on this particular mission in March of
2021 it was Rob and Tim's turn at the
controls and while they knew they
weren't going to be the first to go that
deep
well they found a way to make history
anyway and you hold the record for what
for the deepest beer in history
turns out that depth defying titanium
sphere down in The Frigid Waters of the
deepest place on earth makes calls for a
pretty good beer cooler too the hot end
this because it has the best gold big
it's the best in the bottom of the ocean
it was a toast to Ingenuity to
friendship and Victor viscobo's
childhood dream
a real-life Captain Nemo who built a
machine
that is the stuff of fantasy
somewhere in the nether regions of the
Pacific I'm Lee County for CBS Saturday
morning
that was awesome it was I tell you I'm I
I I can't even imagine getting into that
cockpit if that's what you call it right
the vessel I guess but but the idea of
going down and not knowing how it goes
back up
completely what do you think I'm good
I'll stay I'll stay I'll stay how about
you yes yes totally we'll have more from
these Adventures by the way Thursday on
CBS mornings